so where does the glasgow climate pact
leave the planet well before the un
summit the real world action by
countries to cut greenhouse gas
emissions put us on course for 2.7
degrees of warming above pre-industrial
age temperatures by the end of this
century
that's well above the one and a half
degrees the point at which most
scientists believe the climate will
become dangerously unstable
two weeks of negotiations have taken us
closer to that goal but we're still well
short
with the targets that countries are
committed to by 2030 we're heading for a
rise of around 2.4 degrees
even in the most optimistic scenario
where longer term and still woolly
commitments to net zero are taken into
account we're heading for an average
temperature rise of around 1.8 degrees
those small differences really matter
let's compare the world at one and a
half and two celsius a gap of just half
a degree
well the number of people around the
world facing at least one severe heat
wave every five years would rise from
420 million to 1.7 billion
lack of rain would increase the
population facing severe drought from
133 million to 195 million rising sea
levels would increase people affected by
coastal flooding from 60 million a year
to 72 million a year by 2095 and hunger
would increase as crop yields fall for
mason corn down six percent with an even
bigger drop of nine percent at two
degrees and it's not just humans
affected the proportion of insects that
lose most of the area they were like to
live in would rise from six percent to
eighteen percent and they underpin whole
food chains
we are running out of time to rain in
global warming the average temperature
is up 1.2 degrees since pre-industrial
times and we've already seen record high
temperatures this year in north america
and the mediterranean while in central
europe there was devastation caused by
extreme rainfall as the u.n secretary
general has said climate change is
moving faster than we are